And I'll be presenting our data on a combinatorial cell therapy with ORCA-T and allogeneic CAR-T
for high-risk BALL.
So following up on what Logan said and summarized so beautifully, we know that in the setting
of autologous CD19 CAR-T cells for BALL, there's low durable remission rates.
So I'm showing here the data for ZUMA3 with Brexacel and Felix-Obacel.
When we look at those publications for both of these studies, what we find is exactly
what Logan was saying is that in the patients who retrieved CAR-T cells on those studies,
that the exposure to transplant either pre- or post-CAR-T was about 60%.
So this is showing us that the patients who are getting CAR-T are getting allotransplant
at some point during their course of therapy.
Our Stanford experience with novel cell therapies is something that I want to highlight just
briefly.
Before getting into the trial, some of you may be familiar with the ORCA-T graft, which
is a graft engineered strategy that came out of research from the laboratory of Rob Negrin,
where they found that regulatory T cells help to prevent graft versus host disease.
As a result, this was translated to the clinic, to ORCA-Bio, and they have a phase three clinical
trial that was just published in Blood earlier this year.
Essentially, the approach with this graft engineering strategy allows for the isolation
of the graft.
So this is just a demonstration of the hematopoietic stem cells and the regulatory T cells, as
well as T-cons, such that the Tregs and HSPCs are delivered or administered on day zero
and T-cons on day two.
Another cell therapy that I want to highlight, which is relevant to the clinical trial that
I'm about to report on, is an autologous bispecific CD1922 CAR that came out of Crystal
Mackel's lab.
It's a CAR for which we readily had vector for manufacturing at Stanford.
The publication from that.
Nature Medicine in 2021 did show in the subset of patients with BALL, 17 patients who received
BALL on that trial, that the overall response rate was 100% with a CR of 88%, but the durable
remission was also limited.
And one of the reasons for that, when they did deeper analysis of the CAR signaling,
is that they found that, in fact, the CAR predominantly signaled through CD19 and the
CD22 signaling was limited.
So it was effectively a CD1941BB CAR.
But, because we had that vector readily available, we wanted to look at these two approaches
in combination.
And part of that rationale or desire to combine allotransplant and CAR-T as a post-transplant
prophylaxis against relapse came from some preclinical data from my time as a postdoc
at Memorial Sloan Kettering in the lab of Marcel Vandenbrink, where we found that
administration of CAR-T cells in the post-transplant setting had a low signal of
graft-versus-host disease.
So we thought this was a viable strategy to translate.
As a result, we developed this allocar transplant, or we call it ACT, and this is ACT-1 because
we're now working on ACT-2, the strategy of combining allocar with transplant.
So our hypothesis was that for patients with high-risk BALL who received a myeloblative
ORCA-T from a matched-related or unrelated donor, and I'll highlight that we did
incorporate unrelated donors as well because we amended our protocol to include donors,
not just from the NMVP.
We hypothesized that the addition of the donor CAR-T cells would augment graft-versus-leukemia
without increasing acute graft-versus-host disease, grade 3 or 4, or graft failure.
Our primary endpoint was to assess the incidence of engraftment without grade 3 to 4 GVHD at
day 42.
You can see our key secondary endpoints.
We also incorporated others.
And key eligibility was adult patients, good performance status, high-risk BALL features who had,
and eligible matched donor.
And these are the three CAR-T cell doses.
So the lowest dose was 1 times 10 to the 6 CAR-positive cells per kilogram, all the way up
to the dose level 3, 3 times 10 to the 6, and we used a Bayesian dose escalation design.
So here is the strategy.
So I'll walk you through because it is a bit complex.
So for our eligible donors, they underwent two cell collections.
The first was a leukophoresis, so that was steady state, and those leukophoresis,
products were then used for the CAR-T manufacturing.
Next, the donor underwent a GCSF-mobilized apheresis, which was used for the ORCA-T engineering.
At the same time, the eligible donor, patients eligible for myeloblative conditioning,
underwent their myeloblative conditioning with TBI, PSI, or bufluthaotepa.
And then you can see day 0 got the stem cells and Tregs, day 2, the Tcons, which again is a part of the
approach, and we added on to day 2, CAR-T cell infusion.
Day 3 was tacrolimus, and then again, our safety endpoint in day 42.
So for the inclusion, we enrolled 18 patients, of which 16 got the combined cell therapies.
One patient had CAR manufacturing and then couldn't proceed because of infectious complications,
and then that was before they even got the transplant, and then there was one,
patient who got a transplant and no CAR-T because the day before the CAR-T infusion,
she had a metanuma virus infection and for that reason didn't get the CAR-T.
So here are the characteristics of the patients who were included, median age of 31,
majority were Hispanic, which really tracks with the BALL population in California, so
70% were Hispanic.
The high-risk features that you see could have been in multiple high-risk features in a patient,
those are noted there, and prior therapies of note.
I want to just show that the majority of the patients had a matched sibling donor.
So in terms of the safety, no delays in engraftment, you can see the numbers of acute and chronic
graft-versus-host disease, so all low-grade and resolved patients are on no ongoing immune
suppression for that.
Low rates of CRS and ICANS, and one patient developed, you know, occlusive disease and
subsequently had normal resolution of hepatic function at day 42.
Fifteen of the patients had MRD-negative CR and two patients had an MRD-positive CR by
clonoseq, but otherwise BCR-able and fluocytometry-negative, and this data was just
recently updated with a date cutoff of March 15th.
In terms of the median follow-up, we have about a year and a half of median follow-up.
All patients are surviving and disease-free survival is also 100%.
Our long-term...
Our longest patient is out to almost three years.
So here is a swimmer's plot showing the 100% MRD-negativity by fluocytometry, BCR-able,
and clonoseq, and I just want to draw your attention to a couple of things on this.
So baseline, seven patients were MRD-positive, one patient had active disease, and so in
the two that were MRD-positive post-transplant, subjects four and subject 11, at the last
clonoseq assessments, they are now clonoseq zero.
So there's a lot of evidence that that's not true, and I think it's important to keep
that in mind as well.
We do note that there is long-term CAR-T cell persistence.
So by fluocytometry in the top line, the majority of those cells that are persisting are the
CD4 subset, which really tracks with data that we've seen from long-term CAR-T cell
persistence.
We're in the process of analyzing additional samples so we can have more robust numbers
for that analysis, and also for the qPCR from a quantitative perspective, they're showing
long-term persistence.
QPCR and CAR facts are correlating well.
We didn't see any issues with donor chimerism, as you can see here, both for CD3 and whole
blood.
So in summary, we have the understanding that most adults with high-risk BALL who receive
CAR also received a synchronous allotransplant during their treatment course, that in adults
with high-risk BALL, ACT with allocar and ORCA-T led to durable remission.
So we believe that ACT is a rational approach that merits further investigation.
For high-risk B-cell malignancies, as well as other malignancies, correlative data suggests
that these CARs are persisting beyond one year, and so now we're going to be doing some deeper
correlative analysis.
With that, I would like to acknowledge Lori Muffley, the PI of the study.
I am the IND holder.
Also, our faculty and funding sources and manufacturing, etc.
Thank you so much.